welcome ladies and gentlemen I'm
accompanied by my two good friends mr.
Slattery of Kansas and mr. lent of New
York we're prepared to answer any
questions that you might choose to raise
with regarding to the conduct of the
committee's business this morning I see
mr. Eckhart has come in so ladies and
gentlemen if you have questions please
wait before before before we do that let
me see whether either mr. Lynch are mr.
Slattery or mr. Eckhart has any comments
they wish to make this particular time
mr. milton was
committee has received the testimony of
many over the years we've conducted many
hearings of this kind we have had many
who have appeared before the committee
after having indicated that they
intended to take the fifth this is not
an unusual procedure it has been done in
many instances and I think no inference
can be drawn with regard either to the
conduct of mr. Milken nor can I think
any inferences be with be drawn with
regard to the conduct or the behavior of
the committee the rules require that the
business of the committee be conducted
in the open and indeed for the purposes
of closing a meeting of the committee is
necessary for the committee to have a
vote of the members with a quorum
present input at which a majority vote
to close the proceedings mr. Milken is
possibly facing either in this form or
elsewhere serious questions about the
conduct of his business and I believe it
would been inappropriate for the
committee to either deny him the
opportunity to be heard if he so chose
or it would have been inappropriate to
conduct the business of the committee
behind closed doors without the gravest
of reasons
we apply any set of circumstances that
the private conversations
is not sufficient to assert protections
the Otter Creek account is one of a
number of accounts in which were
conducted inside the offices of Drexel
Burnham Lambert and they are defined in
the language of the Securities Exchange
Commission certain cases at the
different courts of appeals with as as
being quote insider accounts closed
quote we are inquiring to find out how
the monies that were paid into those
accounts by different persons were used
and how those accounts might have been
used to serve the interests of the
people who were members of those
particular accounts and also how the
purchases of securities by those
accounts impacted upon other investors
who were also at the same time seeking
to purchase the same securities which
were being purchased by the participants
in those insider accounts
we can say this that in a number of
accounts administered inside the rubric
of quote insider accounts close quote
there were a number of participants who
were officers and employees of drexel
burnham later included in those in that
category would have been mr. Milken is
the
criminal want to
we are not alleging criminal wrongdoing
at this time we are requiring into how
these matters were handled by drexel
burnham lambert by its officers and
employees and by its high risk bond
division we also are inquiring into how
these actions affected others who would
have invested in the bond market and
whether or not those matters did comply
with different federal statutes and
regulations and we are also inquiring
into whether or not there is need for
additional changes in the law to address
shortcomings which might exist with
regard to those kinds of activities we
pursue this investigation or even let it
go since mr. Melton lamantia breasts
have a hearing scheduled for tomorrow
and we will have other hearings
scheduled for later on at tomorrow's
hearing we will be hearing from mr.
Joseph the chief executive officer of
drexel burnham lambert and we will have
as i mentioned other hearings scheduled
subsequently there too you will observe
that we have had a pattern of hearings
and a sequence of hearings on these and
related matters on activities in and
affecting the securities markets of the
United States now going back about two
years listen mrs. Jerry
ensign with accounts I do not have an
answer to that question at this time I i
said i do not have an answer that that i
think means that i don't know and i will
i will reform it if you wish the
gentleman over
well depending on on which of the many
or the aggregates it was very large many
millions of dollars in some instances
the monthly assets of a single one would
Michael would Brian would exceed a
hundred million dollars in what instance
is 129 believe we had another one which
was larger than 140 140 140 140 million
dollars wanted to in one account in one
account at one time
issue
we are we are looking both at the
primary market and at the secretary
market you will observe that the primary
market is a market at which the
securities are marketed initially and
those are marketed usually at a low
price in some instances the secondary
market has a higher price and we are
looking at both the spread and how these
securities moved between the two markets
jump
cottages are looking at
what are they we are looking at a number
of them there are three in number that
have been reported in the press with
which I'm sure you're familiar there are
there are there will be a number of
others in which we will be inquiring as
a business the committee goes forward at
this particular moment we're we're
concentrating on three but at other
times we will begin dealing with others
and I cannot tell you that tomorrow
sharings will not go beyond the three
into which we are at this minute
inquiring this jump in everything that
you found proves to be pretty but it's
worth life who's injured what was done
to the small
well that's always a good question in
the worst-case scenario it is possible
to raise questions as to whether the
subsequent purchasers of these high-risk
securities got the same price as the
initial purchasers it is also to be
observed that in some instances there is
evidence to believe that the purchasers
on the secondary market not only paid a
higher price but were foreclosed from
buying the full amount that they had
requested in their bid to the firm it
would appear that they then were
compelled to purchase these same
securities in the secondary market at
greater cost and there is there have
been questions raised about whether or
not this complies with the law relative
to amongst other things else insider
trading front-running and possible of
questions raised with regard to what
might be defined under the law as market
manipulation and the victims then would
be if if such there were and I want to
make it very clear we are not charging
crimes at this particular time it is not
our function so to do we are inquiring
as to whether or not these matters
complied with the statutes and with the
regulations issued by the sec on these
matters we were also inquiring as to the
amount of the adverse impact on
subsequent purchasers who had previously
sought to buy larger amounts of the
junk bonds in question
and subsequently day
I'm not making a statement of that kind
the three cases you were looking at is
beatrice foods expiring in our patrolmen
go to the truth are you Laura well
obviously this particular minute our
queries are directed to drexel it is not
beyond the realm of possibility that our
inquiry goes for the forward that we
will be inquiring into others in the
same Martin but at this particular time
our inquiries relate to drexel how i
found that out for coming as special
burden
we have received documents from drexel
burnham at our request or as of this
particular time we have not had to
assert to subpoena again a structural
burnham lambert
I don't know what the answer that is did
we receive questioned documents for mr.
Milken the answer is no we asked for
them from the firm and we received we
have received most of the documents i
believe from the firm that had been
requested we are currently evaluating
the documents received to see see
whether they're in full compliance with
the requests the committee and i don't
want you to think that my response
indicates to you that i'm telling you
that they have not they have not
complied with the response with the
request to the committee one more
question young lady in the back and then
get it off will I be with well it's
early to tell you what we will be doing
with regard to the findings of the
committee I like to make those judgments
after we have completed the hearings and
we have had a chance to evaluate what
the what the committee has found ladies
gentlemen I want to thank you all mr.
and let you have a comment mr. Slattery
you know the only point that I would add
to what the chairman has said is is that
there's been some concern expressed
perhaps by some that this committee
doesn't have a writer responsibility to
be looking into this matter and I would
like to just emphatically reject that
the reality is this committee has
responsibility for securities law and
overseeing the SEC and as far as I'm
concerned we have not only a right but a
a responsibility to do what we're doing
and to explore exactly what has been
going on inside the high-yield bond
market and that's what we're attempting
to do so I reject categorically any
suggestion that this committee doesn't
have the responsibility and the right to
do exactly what we're doing
differs from that another
Derek drexel burnham lambert I'll just
respond to that question you asked why
we chose regretful Drechsel has been the
largest marketer of high-risk bonds
Drexel Burnham Lambert has been the the
for all intents and purposes the market
maker in these areas and the committee
has received a number of questions with
regard to some of the issues that were
dealt with by that particular firm and
it is for those reasons that we're
making these inquiries with regard
drexel burnham lambert today I have told
you that there's strong possibility we
will be inquiring into other firms and
other issues both by drexel and by
others at future time this inquiry is in
its most early stages and as matters
develop we will proceed to address
questions that might be either important
or might arise as we go forward thank
you all very much it was what is your
viewing of the hearing this morning and
you feel that it should have been held
in public my view of the hearing I think
it was a perfectly proper hearing and I
think it was important that we have mr.
Milliken before the committee I have no
qualms about the manner in which the
hearing was conducted I think it was
fair had to be done and tomorrow
hopefully with mr. Joseph will have a
fuller explanation of some of the
transactions that have actually taken
place among the some of the members of
the board of drexel burnham and their
employees he will testify my
understanding is that mr. Joseph is
going to testify and will not seek the
protection of the Fifth Amendment
was their division sharp division on the
committee about this here so far as I'm
aware there was not a sharp division
certainly not on my part
hey I don't really have any comment on
that I can say this they have not been
in touch with me I haven't talked to
anyone and I'm a New Yorker so my my
questions were submitted to the
stenographer today and our part of the
record i would assume there there's no
reason why you couldn't have access to
them to furnish you with with a copy
well the chairman mentioned they were a
number of cases where the committee had
chosen to inquire three particularly i
have a fourth that involves this Home
Shopping Network where though there are
some some questions in my mind that I
want to inquire into and I will tomorrow
when I have that opportunity of mr.
Joseph as to whether there was some
self-dealing within a certain of the
employees including mr. Milliken of
drexel burnham with respect to some junk
bonds that were issued you said in the
opening statement that these cases you
were dealing with today were not under a
federal investigation I didn't make an
opening statement oh I at the hearing i
did make it my understanding is there
are sec and Justice Department
investigation is pending as with respect
to three at least of the transactions
which won't go there you know well the
Chairman is mentioned the one I don't I
off the top of my head I don't have the
names of them excuses that you're
looking into being looked into by the
feds as well it's my understanding they
are and that is why the witness today
asserted the Fifth Amendment because
this is the same more or less the same
these subjects that we inquired of them
today may be the same issues or the same
general territory that he was inquired
of as your witness before the grand jury
I don't know that no one does
well the chairman indicated a minute ago
that with respect to just one of them
the end of the month balance was 140
million dollars and there was a great
deal of money that was turned in and
churned out of that particular account
over the course of a given month and
over a long period of time so oh and
this was only one and there may have
been as many as 20 to 30 of these
accounts which employees of drexel
burnham participated in and were able to
rightly or wrongly and I don't mean to
pass any judgment on them were able to
acquire these junk bonds for their own
account at a at a given price and then
hold them for a rather short periods of
time and then sell them subsequently to
third parties customers of the firm at
substantial increases in value
you got it pretty good pretty good
operation if you can do it
I didn't say there was a violation of
the 34 Exchange Act and mr. Joseph I
assumed tomorrow will indicate to us why
in his opinion there may not have been a
violation we will but even though it may
not be a violation does not mean that
the Congress ought not to look at the
way the law is being conducted and with
the view toward possibly changing the
law maybe this practice maybe this
practice is perfect